oui bonjour Mélanie bogel cétait
important d'être réuni socialiste
écologiste et communiste autour d'une
même banderole évidemment que c'est
important au moment où les actes
antisémites sont en progression
terrifiante en France où nos
compatriotes juives et juifs ont peur
c'est notre responsabilité historique
politique de marcher ensemble contre
l'antisémitisme donc contre le racisme
contre la haine et donc contre l'extrême
droite aussi il manque une déformation
de la Nupe la France insoum
on le comprend elle n'a pas souité
participer elle n'aurait pas été le
bienvenu aussi derrière cette banderole
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez non je
crois que c'est c'est un choix que je
partage pas qui consiste à considérer
que on déserte certaines luttes parce
que le rassemblement national les
instrumentalise au profit du racisme et
nous au contraire nous pensons l'inverse
nous pensons que oui aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national a une stratégie
qui consiste à instrumentaliser la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme à des fins
racistes et notre responsabilité c'est
pas de les laisser faire c'est pas de
les laisser occuper cet espace c'est au
contraire d'affirmer qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes là aussi pour marcher contre eux
contre tout ce qu'il porte et al
justement une dernière question on le
sait que plus loin dans le cortège il y
a des élus du rassemblement national une
quarantaine de parlementaires qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque des facto de marcher
au même rassemblement
que ça m'évoque ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est une stratégie pensée de la
part de l'extrême droite ils ne sont pas
en train de marcher contre
l'antisémitisme ils sont en train
d'essayer d'utiliser notre lutte pour la
dignité humaine pour l'égalité des
droits à des fins racistes et donc je
veux leur dire ceux qui sont derrière
ceux qui sont devant et tous celles et
ceux qui militant en extrême droite
voulent marcher aujourd'hui que c'est
aussi contre eux contre leur idéologie
que nous sommes toutes et tous
rassemblés et bien merci merci Mélanie
Vogel sénatrice écologiste des Près
établie hors de France vreaction au
micro de DEP Sénat et LCP merci Quentin
Calmet